you
hello guys i'm ryan right guys i'm
andrew andrew and i today we're gonna
have a little spoiler discussion spoiler
talk I don't want to entitle this review
because I really just want to have a
talk about it you know like I don't want
to like write down all these [ __ ]
notes because we're gonna be doing a
film analysis of it on his channel movie
source but people have been asking me to
already cover some spoilers of the film
so here we are today here we are today
and I gotta say from beginning to end
this is one of the most exciting comic
book movies I've ever seen
just from the opening credits I remember
you told me that you know someone who
caught a pre-screening and said that the
opening credits is the funniest opening
credits you'll ever see and from that
very first one you know like it was from
the opening credits you're like this is
a different movie this is a very
self-aware film right here yes super
meta yeah I mean no I agree and also too
if you noticed they didn't put anybody's
real name in there was like yeah
directed by an overpaid tool starring
some idiot uh you know also starring
comic relief yeah yeah well so starting
a British villain yeah just so much
greater than and also it let us know
like this is like you said a different
kind of superhero film just a different
kind of film in general and I just loved
so much of the self-awareness I can't
believe that 20th Century Fox let them
get away with it and also just they were
making fun of themselves all throughout
the venom I thought that was just so uni
in some ways in some weird ways I was
like this is the closest live-action
Family Guy annotation we could get in
terms of like the breakaways the
cutaways to like breaking the fourth
hole and talking to an audience and
telling them stuff like that like yeah
it was very very very amusing the whole
time and just the opening sequence when
he's riding in the cab and it takes it
in such a different approach to an
origin movie you know yeah I love how it
would cut back and forth yeah how very
well done because I thought about it and
if they had only if they had started
directly from
the beginning and told this in linear
timeline mm-hmm the tone would not have
been established well it wouldn't have
been felt so when Deadpool becomes like
crazy wacky breaking the fourth wall
Deadpool because I noticed he doesn't do
that he only has like one line where he
does that he only has like no he has
like one or two moments where he does
that when he holds up the toy of the you
know when Deadpool got his mouth so yeah
from the x-men origins Wolverine a right
so when he holds up the toy and the
other one is when he's saying don't make
the suit green or animated or animated
you know right and so in that moment
right there because I know this when it
cuts to the past they don't really do
the wacky stuff so much but what made it
work is they kept Ryan Reynolds sense of
humor throughout they never lost Wade
Wilson's personality so even though it
wasn't as wacky and goofy they never
lost the personality oh yeah for sure no
it's not like you know again the only
thing that changed him obviously his
face got messed up with you know cuz he
took a form of cancer on his face and
now he's able to regenerate himself but
his personality has not changed he's got
the same sense of humor before he gets
the mask and the superpowers and all
that he's the same guy nothing has
changed other than regeneration and he
looks like Freddy Krueger with a topical
map of Utah on his face writers that
what weasel said right yeah weasels yeah
and I got to tell you the relationships
in this movie or the chemistry between
all the actors I can't think of really a
weak performance I'm like I didn't like
the banter between those two weasel and
Deadpool fantastic Francis and Deadpool
great I really thought he was a true
menacing villain for what you know this
call for and I love that this phone was
a revenge so it's not like every other
comic film where it's the end of the
world and you know we've gotta unite as
a team yeah even mentions like yeah
always wears making fun of what you get
when you're a superhero yeah you get
contract yeah contract lucrative deals
yeah you get a team forming movie so
yeah they were making just fun to the
superhero genre in general I was just so
clever I think what really made this
movie cool was it was a revenge story
yes but this movie tells you at the very
beginning about the theme of the film
which is really love and that is the
last thing you'd expect when you go to
watch Deadpool me
and from everything you know that you're
gonna walk away with a great love story
cuz by the end I love that moment when
she kisses him yes because I'm like oh I
guess I'm looking I'm looking at him my
god I look so repulsive there's no way
she's gonna want to be with him but she
really just sees who he is on the inside
she wanted him to survive she wanted him
to live so he is living and even though
it's [ __ ] so much with the way he
looks she still loves him for who he is
on the inside and I love that III was so
[ __ ] sweet it was like sweet and I
smiled when when they were like when
they actually kissed like because a net
the way they wrote Vanessa was so
[ __ ] good it was like listening to a
real woman talking he went up with his
sense of humor you know like cracking
all these kinds of dark jokes and she's
beyond just sarcastic she was a full
three-dimensional character who you
could tell how to heart it was sexy and
was sweet at the same time like when
she's telling she's telling them at the
end maybe with a few drinks I'm like
what other female character in a comic
book movie a Marvel movie to is gonna
say that yeah I think I even heard
someone in the crowd when she said like
I want her so bad like I mean I was
thinking that throughout the film but
just in general no you nailed it I mean
the whole film could have really fallen
apart if that really if the chemistry
between those two actors in work and
kudos to Ryan Reynolds and marina Bakken
from Gotham and she's also the voice of
Gideon on flash season 1 their chemistry
is phenomenal and you buy it from the
opening scene when they're just when
they're going back and forth between the
jokes like I'm like they are perfect for
each other
and then the scene where they're having
sex throughout the seasons happy happy
Thanksgiving happy Chinese New Year and
then see where she's Bonham he's like no
no no no no oh this is perfect it was a
wonderful montage like this all this
movie is so clever in a way where when
you first saw this not twice and the
first time you watch it I don't think
you're gonna catch on as well as how
clever
this is because when you re watch it
you're like wow this is why everything
works
you know because going back to the love
story yes
watching it I was like damn I'm so
invested in this even the second time
I'm watching it and this is why I give a
[ __ ] so [ __ ] much you know like of
course everything's great about it that
we expected the comedies fantastic the
breaking the fourth wall is great Ryan
Reynolds rocks the actions really
[ __ ] cool but the core of this film
is is is the love story and I like how
the film wasn't shy to make it about
that they weren't shy about anything no
they really weren't yeah and they push
the boundaries a lot like even with the
violence one he cuts off his own arm
when he got shot in the [ __ ] means
right up Main Street said it perfectly
and also to I felt like she wasn't a
damsel in distress she was a smart
character like even you know at the end
where he they're on a helped by the way
the second time I noticed they're on a
health health carrier from the Avengers
series
oh yeah that's a health carrier a
Helicarrier from the Anthony Winter
Soldier and the Avengers films one of
those health carriers that's that check
it out next time you watch it but it's
for sure one of those anyways the point
being she's like strapped in that
machine that's you know sucks away your
oxygen and you know Wade throws of the
night add the sword and the thing and
then you know she has to K you know she
cuts herself and then like to get out
she like cuts herself basically and then
she stabs Francis and she saved him
she's easily could've stood off to the
side and been like no you you you you go
say okay so they gave her a purpose and
also the again you were so invested that
you just wanted a way to do anything
possible to save this woman then when
she just accepts him at the end you're
like like I love these two I want them
to be together so bad it's a perfect
absolutely the chemistry is so
undeniably didn't make any like DC jokes
about the fact that she was in it you
know because like with her life with her
being on Gotham and an VN flashy like I
would expect like at least one DC joke I
don't know if they wanted to start
trouble right well not with her they
didn't but there was a Batman and Robin
and obviously on the Green Lantern ones
what he's talking to blind or he's
talking to blind now and he's
like you know she's just like Robin
except she's black she's blind and but
you know and she loves me I think Robin
loved that man also that was cool little
mention right there but yeah I agree the
chemistry between them was like you
can't I can't think of too much better
chemistry I've seen in a comic book film
I think you know pepper and and Tony
Stark
that's great chemistry a Gwen Stacy and
and Andrew Garfield but that's pretty
much what's cool about this is they made
it an r-rated film but they didn't pg-13
the romance they they start off just oh
surely it has two in each other you know
yeah then it grows to love and I'm like
that's real life right you know that is
[ __ ] real life you know you you start
[ __ ] getting so horny for each other
you're so attracted and then you fall in
love in in these pg-13 movies they
haven't even had sex yet and they're
like our love with you yeah feel so
forced and this just felt so natural it
was not forced in any way I agree with
you absolutely and I didn't talk about
the semi and my non-spoiler review but
Colossus yes I watched x-men 2 and 3
before watching Deadpool again I watched
x-men 1 2 3 and origins just because I
was trying to get the Deadpool vibe
going at me like wanting to see the
reboot but hey so I watched that and
Colossus is not really a character in 2
& 3
yes hey he's American right and I like
how they crack that joke about the
excellent timeline not make you much
sense
come on you're Stewart yeah I can't
confuse between the timeline as everyone
knows a continuity within timelines of
the x-men world is like so cool it is so
when so when Colossus shows up I'm like
okay he's apparently Russian yeah yeah
in x-men 2 & 3 is not on Russian but I
really like what they did with him they
it was like that's an odd choice to have
what's the girl's name though
negasonic teenage warhead it's it was an
odd choice to see like okay they got
negasonic teenage boy wasn't it Ripley
from aliens three shower Sinead O'Connor
is actually alien 3 sorry
alien 3 and my fault so we got the
teenager and then we got Colossus and
it's like
those are two interesting characters to
choose but but it works and it felt more
like a comic book because of the fact
that they included they actually used
xavier x' the setting of the mansion
they they had colossus and they had
these these two characters and it does
feel like that when you're reading a
comic and then oh these people from the
other part of the universe are appearing
and it wasn't like here's a fun cameo
it's like let's make them actual
characters and let's take x-men
characters that weren't really you know
focused on her and one that hasn't been
introduced and they made it and shine
know like they owe Colossus has never
been better in cinema and like it and
they have personality I you really got
his character that he was like yeah all
about being a hero
so even when Deadpool shoots Francis in
the end then you see Colossus and a huge
that that right there I'm like there's
so much more personality to Colossus
than ever before
thank God they chose them and it was not
the typical approach you would hope for
like I don't think anyone heard about
deaf wonder like I hope Colossus and
what's negasonic at Masonic teenage
warhead is in it like no one was
thinking that but two wonderful choices
made it really feel more like a comic
book absolutely - and also when we
showed that when they were shown
Colossus and he would started throwing
up after Deadpool :
I love others showing he's from a pg-13
universe he's not used to seeing guys
brains being splattered and all that
graphic violence he's used to you know
there's part of the x-men they they
don't you know kill Kai's like that in
vain so I thought that was really really
clever showing that he's not in he's not
used to this and then negasonic teenage
warhead or Ellen Ripley from alien 3 is
Deadpool like the color I thought she
was so unique she wasn't the Moody teen
as they put it in the title and the
original titles of the film the opening
credits she was just a really unique
character the banter between her and and
Deadpool was awesome and like where he
called her al ripley he was like there
she was like [ __ ] you're old and like
just a lot of great lines like then her
powers were awesome not watching her in
action was like she's a badass I loved
watching her and I love to
the film they make reference of why
there's no other x-men in the film Ryan
ran our Deadpool Rather's leg
Boyd so wonder why there aren't any more
x-men in this in this mansion I guess
the the studio couldn't afford more
characters yeah I just thought that was
unique into all the huge dude I got a
mansion Hugh Jackman is a trooper to let
them let him make this much fun of him
with all and with the stuff on the face
and also if you notice too when he rips
off the mask and where Vanessa really
like just accepts him for who he is just
one of the greatest moments in the film
he's got a Hugh Jackman stickier stapled
from head to and to chin stapled on his
face from the front view it looks like
it's Hugh Jackman obviously with the
mask but then from the back view with
the camera it looks like it's Iron Man's
mask yeah so I thought that was an
interesting looking shot right there but
just again there were just so many great
moments in the film and the chemistry
between the relationships between all
the the characters you just bought it
was really good well done Oh true yeah I
mean going back to where you're saying
it I love the point about how I love the
point about you know because in the
opening credits they have they list all
these cliches they leave all these
cliches yet you watch the movie and I'm
like these characters are unique though
they're not just cliches like they're
the cliche but layered and added on to
and developed so it's way more than just
that like Francis for example was a
really well-written villain at first
they show him and when they introduce
him it was interesting because he gets
stabbed so you think this guy's gonna
die oh yeah and then you're like oh wait
a minute he doesn't even look like he's
in pain you know yeah and he escapes and
I was like why because I was thinking
like why is Deadpool hunting a guy
that's taking him like over a year to
find and when they shot me see he's also
very intellectual he's beyond having
super-strength and not able to feel pain
he's very intellectual he's a scientist
so seeing that was really [ __ ] cool
that good it wasn't like oh he gets his
powers at the end and fights deadpool
you know it's like it starts off and
he's already got the mutant gene
and whatever the [ __ ] I put in him right
no you just basically said a cliche for
most superhero films where they get the
power at the end and then fight him but
no I agree with you and also he was
really menacing like when he's putting
Ryan or Wade Wilson in the oxygen tube
and like I felt so claustrophobic
claustrophobic in that moment and also
it made me think of that film with Ryan
arounds buried like it just it just it
really made me feel like I felt like you
could feel the have the struggle between
the two characters and I thought he
played it off I think he's also in
transporter right that actor I think you
are but like you said he just did an
amazing job of making you feel terrified
for Wade Wilson like even though you
know Wade Wilson's got regeneration
powers like this guy is not afraid to
hurt he hurt him from the moment he says
what's my name
like he's menacing he just he sells it
like that could have been so funny where
he's like what's my name you could have
been a cheesy typical British villain
there was a plot to it and sing and you
know what Gina Carano probably gonna be
like well she doesn't what she has like
you want two lines in the whole film
still though still worth that for that
cliche bodyguard
yeah I thought I was still interested
when she was on screen I was still like
she has an intensity about her she is
pretty to look at but you could tell
she's [ __ ] tough as hell you know and
so she is intimidating at the same time
and her and Colossus fighting was a
great fight great so I thought it was
cool I thought it was cool seeing her
into people separately on she's a shitty
actress then I watch it I'm like you
know hey this is good that she was in it
I could see why they cast her yeah no
they had to make it a little believable
even though the woman has superpowers I
had to make it a little believable that
a woman's gonna punch Colossus you know
it's 80 to a hundred feet away on a real
fighter yeah I got a real MMA fighter
makes total sense and yes they gave her
two lines and they it clearly they shot
a little bit around her but it didn't
bother me like I just that accident
scene alone in her superhero landing
weird way yeah like what watch Supergirl
and Supergirl and here it comes here
comes oh boy that's hard on the knees
yeah it's just so well done and again
that action sequence was in crow
have they started the movie with that
amazing action I think was the test
footage right from the yeah
yeah um so like I thought that was
interesting to start it off that like
just going a full you know one-eighth of
120 right there in terms of miles per
hour and then the way they just did the
linear shooting of going back with the
storytelling I just I thought it was
just really well done like totally last
few things I want to mention out the the
black line lady that was a character
that when I saw the trailer I was
worried about is she gonna be the one
that annoys me is she gonna be the one
that's like oh the old lady who's over
the top and so hiding and personality
yeah you watching her like you know what
her personality fits with Deadpool
perfectly Wade Wilson and her perfect
together
she's blind so she never judges the way
he looks and like I could see what
there's way more than that way more like
there's that one scene whether he's
leaning her head his head on her and
then he starts using the little man to
touch her and so yeah that's right it'll
make it look bigger like seeing that I
was like even she was written perfectly
oh yeah she had the right level and and
everything about her was used just well
Stan Lee's cameo oh my god I remember
you saying that that was your favorite
Stan Lee that's mine too just because of
how fold it is and how far it was really
to go it yeah cuz I'm like you can see
like Stan Lee's in the same shot where
there are some tits those are tips and
Stan Lee there Stan Lee the area's
making the announcement about the
stripper who's like having a blast ya
know that was a great Stan Lee cameo
yeah and I think you also mentioned
earlier when we were talking you said it
perfectly he's the Hugh Hefner of the
Marvel comic book universe that only
makes man Iron Man pokes fun at the yeah
and also Iron Man didn't make fun of
that and that can't and the Stan Lee
cameo in that film but it makes just
perfect sense to see him in that kind of
a cameo role yeah by far the most
entertaining and also really quickly
just getting back to Al from the moment
she said to him get a red shirt you
idiot like I was just sold on the
character right there from that first
line dial I'm like they're perfect just
the banter between them
and you said it perfectly they could
have overdone her character and just too
much banter and going back and forth way
they did it to the perfect amount of
time and it was just enough to where
you're like I don't want a little more
and not enough to where you like knots
too much you know so I thought they did
the perfect amount of banter between us
because she's a human being I'm not like
just a woman who complains like when
they when he goes to her home first
thing you see her doing in the home and
she's building something you know IKEA
she's she's blowing and she's trying to
build something and that says so much
about her character that's that's what I
mean you don't realize just how great
the details of this movie are until like
the second time you watch it yeah
because it's so engrossing then you when
you're able to really observe it it's
like wow these writers were clever and
they clap and then they credit
themselves and nobody do with the credit
yeah it's like you're as like something
about like Heather the perfect day
they're the ones or the couple or saying
I was it something like that and also to
like for me personally my favorite line
in the whole film was like when Wiesel
was saying to I'd like I'd loved
I'd love to help you but I don't want to
go yeah and then uses the out right
after after dead Polizzi's like when I
got [ __ ] up I thought the way TJ
Miller was used in this film again same
thing without they used him just the
perfect amount of time that where you
bought the relationship you felt like he
was a good friend even though he did bet
on the way to die in the Deadpool I
thought that was also very clever how
they came up with his name there's so
many films were and they made fun of it
to the like captain Deadpool no you just
didn't know yeah so brilliant there's
just like you said that detail you've
got to watch this movie more than once
like if you see it once and you're not
crazy about it you know I mean given
another chance but if you love this film
see it multiple times because the repeat
value in this film is incredible and
also there's so many Easter eggs and
other things you get to pick up on like
I think you would mentioned earlier when
they're making fun of the Liam Neeson
when he was up at night and she's like
what what's wrong he's like I was just
thinking about Liam Neeson and taken you
know at some point you got to wonder is
he a bad parent like yeah there's just
so many unique self referential things
in this world night I just I want more
Ted Poole movies now and yeah and what I
wanted to say was that it's a complete
film yeah
it's a complete film that tells a whole
story I love that it's not a film that
ends in a way where I'm like well [ __ ]
if I have to finish the story I have to
watch the sequel now no this could
technically be the end it technically
could just be here's the one movie about
Deadpool here's the main story about him
there you go that's cool I love that
there's a part two coming out where I'm
like I want to see it so bad not because
I have to but because I really want to
well said you know um and and last thing
the post-credits ting that I love how
there's what we always expect is for the
character to show up and see like who's
gonna be in the sequel and this one they
were just like cables supposed to be in
it just like totally mocking whatever
the [ __ ] there's no cables gonna be in
and I don't know much about cable I
remember him in the cartoon I want to do
more research on him because I'm super
stoked that they're gonna make a part
two right no I agree with you I'm gonna
definitely do a little more research on
the character - I know he's from the
future as they alluded to in the after
credits sting and also - for me
personally the two actors who I'd like
to see them consider but obviously I
trust whoever they pick Stephen Lang or
Liam Neeson I think would be kick-ass
choices for those for that role and
again like I said I just felt like this
universe works and also I feel like they
infuse the x-men even so well like I can
see more films like even with x-men
coming in it you know where Deadpool
then Joey you know come like an x-force
film you can add where he even joins the
x-men in a film I'm not I don't see him
as an x-men he just does not fit with
what they do but I can see them in a
film for a cause you know working
together for some reason like you saw at
the end of this film where you know he's
like you may gave them a proposition of
helping them and it just it was so
seamless and it worked it wasn't forced
it felt natural even with all the self
references and you know all the jokey
humor you felt real and you felt like
these universes absolutely can co-exist
together I feel like if we were to talk
about the MCU and Fox and the
possibility that I'm working together
I feel like Deadpool could be the link
cuz Deadpool is so about making
everything meta breaking the fourth wall
making out of the world experience that
he I feel like he would be the character
that could somehow be in the world that
is able to make the x-men and The
Avengers world linked together in some
way I feel like that could be the and
same thing with like the Marvel TV shows
like they're like Punisher and daredevil
like the Jessica Jones having all these
characters come together and like
there's even a comic of Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe yes so like I feel
like Deadpool could be the thing that
really brings the Marvel Universe into
full circle that's an interesting theory
I'm also too in the movie they can at
the post-grad singer he actually said
would you expect Samuel Jackson from
with an eyepatch no we don't have that
kind of money
yeah so the technically made a reference
to an MCU moment so you know technically
we can say that right there but it's an
interesting theory edge you know if they
end up do doing that that's great I
wouldn't mind that I do obviously at
this point in time I personally think
that the MCU has enough characters but I
again I don't care whatever I see
Deadpool at this point you know put put
Deadpool in a movie now him and also
marina Bachmann's character Vanessa I'm
in this was one of the best you know you
know what made this film great - it was
a passion project as well oh yeah yonder
tree on a marketing choice and missing -
making a lot of money it was a passion
project for people involved you know
especially Ryan Oh like he has been
pushing for this for years so you could
feel that passion and love behind the
camera so to me it's one of the best
comic book movies of all time I agree
rarely do you see a film where like yeah
these these guys love Deadpool oh you
know so yeah everyone should watch it
absolutely my girlfriend doesn't like
movies like this and I can't think of
another movie like this but violence and
[ __ ] and like you know dick had to leave
characters and she ended up loving it
like it's that good of a film then
you're like yeah it's great um anyway
guys long a spoiler talk if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
because
reject it'll be worth some of your time
andrew has a channel called movie source
check it out link in description box
there's also an annotation in here for
you to click it follow me on Instagram
Twitter and vine fall Andrea on Twitter
do you use anything else really not
really fall Andrew Igor 7-eleven on
Twitter and I know I didn't really crack
many jokes in this review I don't think
I cracked any yeah I feel like your joke
list right now and didn't kind of joke
list today mm-hmm well I felt like we've
let monster the jokes out when we were
talking about Deadpool right it's fun to
be funny when you're reviewing something
funny yeah I agree because it's hard
competition that movie oh yeah I totally
[ __ ] Ryan Reynolds that's not a joke
that's a face I think you could sit on
top of for sure I'd let him sit on me I
heard he's quite a [ __ ]